hello everyone this is the second time
I'm recording this video since the first
time I was interrupted by some children
who were trick-or-treating and they rang
my doorbell so I had to give them some
chocolate before resuming to make my
video so perhaps I will be successful in
this second run like I said I hope
you're all having a great Sunday I just
got back from my chess club where I
finished playing round five of my chess
club championship and my opponent was
Marian Garrett's he's a retired physics
and mathematics professor from my home
town and in this game he has the white
pieces now usually he's a d4 player and
as I mentioned in my video against dodo
I did prepare the Budapest gambit but
those are avoided my preparation so I
thought maybe I'll give the old budapest
gambit I tried this game but again my
opponent completely avoided my
preparation and opened the game with
efore so I thought you're not you're not
an e4 player why are we playing e4 of
course he doesn't want to go into my
preparation so I decided to play b6
if he avoided my preparation I'm pretty
sure b6 avoids any opening preparation
he had so he continued this is the Owens
defense he played d4 I played Bishop to
b7 immediately going after that central
e4 pawn he defended with the Bishop to
d3
now I thought about giving this f5 move
ago but I decided not to as that only
gives a white the advantage I play
Knight to f6 again piling up on the e4
pawn and he defended Queen to d2
I played a six wood the idea that if he
or he wants to protect the e4 pawn I
will have Bishop to b4 pinning that
night but he avoided playing this Knight
to c3 idea so he played Knight to f3 and
I immediately played d5 he played
capture Sun d5 I played Knight captors
on d5 and already it's a pretty
dangerous position if you're not careful
with the white now this knight on d5 is
a pretty nice piece so of course you
want to kick it away with c4 but playing
c4 immediately leads to an extremely
complicated position if white pushes c4
here then after this Bishop to b4 chick
white has to play King to f1 if he tries
to defend this of course you can go
Knight c3 you you lose a pawn at least
and if you try something like rush up to
d2 then comes the knife to f4 and this
is just terrible as you can see that the
bishop is now attacked the queen is
attacked and the g2 point is attacked so
if you try and defend this with
something like Queen to e3 then Knight
captures and g2 wins the Queen and if
you try something like Queen to f1 then
you get a bit of captures on f3
threatening to capture and g2 and after
G characters on f3 now comes Queen
captures on before attacking the bishop
on d3 twice attacking the pawn on b2 so
after something like Bishop to c2 now
you grab on B to Bishop capture some
before and not being captures on c2 not
grabbing the rook but threatening Knight
to d3 check and white is falling apart
apart here
so after this Knight captures on d5 and
my opponent didn't go for c4
instead he played c3 not allowing any
Bishop to b4 or night to be four ideas
here I played Knight to d7 he castled
and I played Bishop to d6 I thought
about the Bishop to e7 but I thought nah
I'm gonna go Bishop to d6 to my to give
my opponent more chances but it might
give me some chances as well and here he
played a three the idea of f3 is he
wants to push c4 but he doesn't want the
one allowed this night to jump to b4
so I really took my time here I thought
about this position for like maybe even
half an hour man okay maybe not half an
hour 25 minutes I'd say and I was
considering a lot of things basically I
was mostly considering Knight to f4 I
wanted to see if this works in my favor
but I saw that after Knight to f4 I do
win the bishop pair either he will
capture with the dis Bishop or he will
move the Queen and then I'll grab the d3
Bishop but I didn't like that after
Bishop captures and Bishop captures he
has this Bishop to e4 offering to
exchange even the light square bishop
and I don't want to exchange my light
square Bishop probably I'd have to play
something like c6 here and I just didn't
like my position here so after this a3
move
consider some other things that
considered maybe in 97 to f6 simply
developing but then maybe I'm allowing
this night to jump to e5 and then he can
consolidate would therefore I didn't
like this idea as well so after giving
this position a lot of consideration I
decided to Castle as I didn't think
there's really anything in the position
to worry about and here probably me
thinking a lot about the position got my
opponent a bit confused as probably
Bishop to g5 is the best idea here
developing the piece going after the
Queen I probably have to decide what to
do here I definitely wouldn't want to
play Bishop back to e7 because then I'm
just admitting Bishop to d6 wasn't such
a great idea probably would have to go
Queen to c8 and then we would just
continue playing this game but he played
Bishop to e3 and after I saw Bishop to
e3 this is a move I haven't even
considered not because he's kind of
forcing me to capture it
I could have captured it whenever I
wanted to simply by playing Knight to f4
of course I'm not gonna capture it now
but one thing I did consider and the
thing I did play is actually this move
e5 and the movie 5 came to mind because
when he played Bishop to e3 the Queen is
no longer protecting a 5 so this gave me
an idea I did give this position some
some thought and I saw that in the end I
will be down upon but that I would like
my position so I played me 5 and here
the the strongest move for him to
consider is actually Bishop to g5 he
didn't play this but if he had after
Bishop to g5 I have to I have to play
Bishop to e7 or f6 but I didn't like f6
and after Bishop captures Queen captures
he can't capture the pawn because if he
captures the pawn he he runs into Knight
to f4 attacking the bishop and the Queen
and after Queen moves not Knight
captures Queen captures and now comes
Knight to c5 attacking the Queen and
also this Bishop is now attacking the
knight on f3
Queen has to protect the Knights of
somewhere not to allow me to break open
the King's position so after Queen to a5
captures captures and now Knight to b3
going there
the rook and also the queen is now
attacking the spawn so after rook moves
I recapture the point so the material is
again equal but my knight and b3 is
really making this white rook look bad
and this Knight mb1 can't be developed
because my knight is covering d2 so
although this would have been best for
black it's it's not what he went for
after this a5 he went for the second
main line so to say he played the
captures I captured he captured and here
I have an option I can either recapture
with the bishop or I can play Knight
captures on e3 if I play Knight captures
on e3 first then after Queen captures
and now I can capture Bishop captures
and now he has the option either of
capturing my bishop on e5 and then I
capture on d3 or he can play Bishop
captures on h7 winning upon and then
grab my Bishop on e5 but then again he
doesn't have to do anything he can
simply play Knight the d to prepare
Knight to f3 and the game continues and
I didn't I didn't like my chances here
after this Knight captures on e5 I
didn't capture on e3 I played Bishop
captures and here I saw that I'm losing
a pawn but I also saw that I will have a
lot of compensation for a pawn and here
he played the immediate Bishop captures
on h7 now this isn't it the best move
although he does win upon the best idea
here is Queen to h5 actually threatening
checkmate and attacking my bishop on e5
and only after I defended this with
Knight to f6 attacking the Queen and
also the h7 point now if he captures my
Bishop I capture his Bishop on d3 so
only now the idea is to capture on h7
Bishop captures Knight captures and then
Queen captures Bishop on e5 and this is
similar to the position that we got but
you'll see that there is quite some
difference because here after this
variation my night is on h7 and the
position is still around equal he's up
upon but I do have this rook coming into
the game with tempo on the Queen I have
this amazing Bishop on b7 so I didn't
mind playing this position but after
this Bishop captures on e5 he went for
the immediate Bishop captures on h7 I
played King captures and after queen age
five check I retreated King to g8 and
now he grabbed my Bishop on e5 and if
you look at this position - the one I
just showed you now I have a knight on
d5 instead of that position where I had
the night on h7 obviously having a
knight on d5 is much better
I played rook to e8 immediately going
for the queen and he played Queen to g3
and not allowing me to capture on e3 and
then capture the pawn then will again
have equal material but again my
position is better due to my lights were
better being a great piece and he's also
somewhat undeveloped here and here I
played rook to e6 as I do have a light
square bishop on b7 i played rook to e6
preparing rook to g6 I'm going for that
g2 blonde so a nice rook lifts I thought
he played Bishop to g5 defending this
this is the best way to defend this and
here I played Queen to d7
I played Queen to d7 for two reasons one
is to have the option of playing Queen
to b5 going after the b2 pawn and the
other reason is I know he wanted to play
c4 and so by playing Queen to d7 I
actually set a little trap
unfortunately my opponent didn't go for
it but I thought maybe he will if he
play something like Queen rook to d1 now
preparing c4 to win a piece but then I
win the game immediately so this is the
first puzzle of the video can you find
the winning move for black here if he
played rook to d1 the move I had in mind
if you pause the video if you found it
congratulations if you just want to
enjoy the show
the move is Knight to f4 and now of
course if he captures the Queen he gets
rook to e1 this is checkmate and if he
doesn't if he ignores this in some way
let's say he moves the rook or he plays
Knight to d2 simply defending then
Knight to e2 wins the Queen and any
other move he plays also it doesn't
really work if you play something like
rook to f1 again 92 wins the Queen there
is no move that can prevent the loss of
the Queen and also prevent checkmate so
I thought this was a pretty pretty nifty
trap but he avoided it after my Queen to
d7
plate Queen to h3 better a better idea
was c4 immediately kicking my night away
probably to e7 and then continuing with
the development for example c4 9700
Knight to c3 white is now developed and
you know the game continues I do have
rook rook to g8 rook to g6 coming but it
would be better than what my opponent
played in the game after Queen to d7 he
played Queen to h3 now pinning my rook
as my queen is undefended here and here
I played Queen to b5 with the idea of
going after the b2 pawn but the b2 pawn
isn't my primary threat my primary
threat is something much greater and
here after giving the position some
consideration my opponent decided to
play b4 and when I saw before I knew
that I was winning the game so here is
the final puzzle of the game do pause
the video and try to find the winning
idea for black here it's not it's not
very difficult it's it's just very very
funny so for those of you who were able
to find the congratulations and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show in this position I played Queen
captures on f1 and after Queen captures
on f1 as you can see it's all over now
the rook is controlling the e-file White
has only one option that is to capture
the Queen and after King captures on f1
after Bishop to a6 it's all over the
King has to go back and then rook to e1
is checkmate there is no piece that can
block this share by the bishop you'd
have to give up a lot of pieces here but
in the end it wouldn't really matter as
no pieces can defend the other piece
after we block it so the end will be the
same King g1 and then rocky one this
will come as checkmate but yeah after
this Bishop to a6 my opponent saw that
there was no way out and he resigned the
game so yeah that's a game from round
five of my chess club championship I do
hope you enjoyed it so far I'm five and
five and two more two more games to go
in this championship so we'll see you
know last year I last year I won first
place with
all wins and I drew one game so we'll
see how I do this year so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Nels Lindberg for a
contribution to my channel thank a lot I
really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon